Vénus et Adonis à gauche et flore et
Zéphyr à droite deux groupes sculptés si
tu habituellement au-dessus des grilles
de l'Orangerie du château de Versailles
actuellement en restauration à
Mantes-la-Jolie ils ont reçu la visite
de 28 collégiens une visite guidée par
Anne-Laure Goron conservatrice et
restauratrice il y a énormément de
choses à dire en réalité parce que ce
sont des sont des œuvres qui déjà
elle-même sont intéressantes dans leur
conception la restauration elle-même
extrêmement intéressante rien que la
dépose a été très complexe c'est
vraiment stimulant de transmettre tout
ça on fait on fait ça en fait on a quand
même un métier qui est un métier de
transmission la transmission du
patrimoine un élément qui a intéressé
les élèves du collège Martin Luther King
de Buc ils ont pu découvrir les secrets
du travail de restauration de ces
statuts j'ai appris la façon dont on
pouvait déplacer une statue pour la
rénover la façon aussi dont on pouvait
la rénover que ce soit remplacer un
membre ou juste la laver j'ai trouvé ça
hyper intéressant parce qu'on a
découvert plein de choses un univers
qu'on ne connaissait pas habituellement
et surtout l'envers enfin derrière une
statue ce qui se passe un peu cette
visite s'inscrit dans un programme de
découverte des métiers d'art une
initiative menée par la professeure
principale de cette classe de 4e le
premier objectif c'est ouvrir la culture
de l'élève à tout ce qui est artistique
là la taille de la pierre ou la
restauration des pierres mais il a aussi
un objectif d'ouvrir le champ des
possibles des métiers dans tout ce qui
est parcours à venir donc réflexion à
l'orientation la rénovation des statuts
va se poursuivre un chantier sur deux
ans rendu possible grâce au conseil
départemental des Yvelines pour les
collégiens le prochain rendez-vous est
prévu lors des Journées Européennes des
Métiers d'Art du 27 mars au 2 avril 2023